hey 42 here in 1266
the monks of san geneve monastery in
france sentenced a criminal to death
for the unimaginably horrific crime of
murdering a child
and eating the body it seems to have
been a cut and dried case
as far as we can tell the condemned
didn't dispute his sentence
although that might be because he was a
pig
and no i don't mean he was a nasty guy
i mean an actual pig
what a swine in a similar case in 1474
a rooster in the swiss city of basel was
tried
convicted and executed for the heinous
and unnatural crime
of laying an egg the event was clearly
the work of satan
and as everyone knows the eggs of
satanic roosters
can contain a cockatrice a dragon-like
creature with two legs
not something you want running around
the breakfast table
in the end the bird was burnt alive and
the body discarded
which was probably a good idea if
there's one thing i've learnt in this
life
it's that you should never eat satan's
[ __ ] no matter how tasty it might look
these cases of capital punishment for
animals
might seem bizarre but they are not
historically unusual
records going back to the 9th century
reveal a long
trend of humans putting animals on trial
for bad behavior culprits have included
insects slugs and snails
leeches weevils small mammals like mice
and rats
big mammals like pigs and cows birds
worms and a monkey suspected of being a
french spy
[Music]
the number of these cases has gradually
declined over the centuries
but it hasn't fallen to zero in 1916
in tennessee a circus elephant named
mary
was lynched for killing her handler an
untrained homeless man who until
24 hours before had never even seen an
elephant
great choice of a handler there in 2004
in kazakhstan
a female brown bear named katya was sent
to an actual human prison
for 15 years after mauling two people
and as recently as 2008 a genuine court
of law in macedonia
convicted a bear for stealing a
beekeeper's honey
the case dragged on for a year whilst
the beekeeper
explains the trouble he had gone through
to frighten the bear off with disco
light
and high tempo serbian folk music
the bear who clearly preferred drum and
bass didn't even have the courtesy to
show up for the court proceedings
but managed to avoid punishment on
grounds of being a protected species
to most people the idea of sending an
animal to prison or
sentencing it to be burned to the stake
even just putting it on trial
seems ridiculous but these stories
actually raise some tricky questions
about
how responsible we humans are for our
own
actions you see the reason animals
across the vast majority of the
civilized world
are not routinely asked to plead guilty
or not guilty
to any crimes they may have committed is
quite simply because they can't and not
just because they don't have the vocal
cords to form the words
most societies correctly consider
animals to be unable to make moral
decisions
in the same way we humans do the
established thinking is that
animals even well-trained ones are
ultimately
slaves to their instincts acting out
their urges without first passing those
impulses
through a filter of morality humans
on the other hand are believed to be
independent free thinking creatures
capable of making good moral judgments
based on this belief when we do make bad
moral decisions
we usually risk some form of punishment
at the hands of
whoever's in charge this view of the
world relies on
the assumption that each of us has free
will
which means we have the freedom to
choose our actions
even if those actions result in us
sharing a prison cell
with a large man named nancy
but what if this view is wrong
what if we actually have no more free
will than bears or pigs
or weevils this question has been
bugging philosophers and legal theorists
but
probably not bears for thousands of
years
and many regard it as unsolvable
over the last few decades neuroscience
and quantum physics
have chipped in with some useful
insights
but the debate still rages do humans
truly have free will and if they don't
what does that mean for how we operate
as a society
if you do something morally wrong is it
completely your fault
how about if you do something amazing do
you really deserve all the credit
you may be watching this thinking what
ridiculous questions
of course i have control over my actions
how else could i be watching youtube in
my underwear
and that makes sense to most of us
because it just feels right
the notion of free will not your
underwear
every day we can point to numerous
decisions seemingly made at our own
discretion
i was hungry i ate a sandwich i was
tired
i went to sleep i was lonely i
remembered to obey the restraining order
simple well not if you agree with casual
determinism
the belief that every event is fully
decided by
some cause that came before that cause
was caused by something
which in turn was caused by something
else
and so on in other words
there are no options or choices there's
just a never-ending chain of cause and
effect
stretching all the way back to the
origin of the universe
you may think you choose to have a
sandwich for lunch
but that choice was determined by a
collection of factors outside your
conscious awareness
that guaranteed your lunchtime blt
was inevitable according to determinism
the impression that you had some
independent role to play in
how those events unfolded is nothing
more
than an illusion perhaps it's all
orchestrated by
a pompous guy who sits in a room full of
tvs and likes to call himself the
architect
it's the thinking behind the ancient
greek myth of the fates
or the moirai free goddesses who decide
the destinies of mortals
when they are born weaving the
individual threads of their lives
into a tapestry of all humankind
their power was so strong that not even
zeus himself
could alter the course of history and he
was basically their boss
similar themes exist in norse mythology
german paganism roman mythology
even shakespeare's macbeth in chinese
myth and legend an invisible red thread
of fate
connects the fingers of two people who
are born to be together
isn't that lovely most of the world's
great religions
also include a version of this for you
in which
god or another form of all-knowing
all-powerful deity
has decided or at least knows in advance
what is to happen
across time fate continues to be a
sticky
idea even in a secular world most people
who regard themselves as
agnostic or atheist have had at least
one experience which seemed
too amazing to have happened by chance
like it was just meant to be
but fate and determinism are not the
same things
strictly speaking belief in destiny is a
type of determinism called
fatalism that says all events are mapped
out in advance
usually by some form of higher power the
grand plan doesn't need to follow any
laws of cause and effect
it just is as if someone once made a
movie about life across all of time
and then pressed play
in ancient greece around the 7th century
bc
the notion began to emerge that it was
fundamental laws of nature
not the gods that decided the events of
our daily lives
philosophers democritus and his mentor
lucipus
developed the idea that we're all made
of atoms
and the motions of these atoms is
decided purely by the natural laws
of causation in their view the future
was entirely determined by the past
as our understanding of the natural
world and the laws that govern it
expanded determinism became increasingly
informed by the emerging disciplines of
science
and few people had a bigger impact on
the development of modern determinism
than isaac newton the 17th century
mathematician
astronomer physicist theologian and
all-around smart guy
when newton developed his laws of motion
and universal gravitation
he appeared to have uncovered the very
rules that govern the universe
giving determinism a scientific
foundation
with newton's principles it became in
theory
possible to accurately predict the
results
that would be caused by almost any
action
in 1814 french scholar pierre simon
laplace
the first person to publish literature
about casual determinism
took this to the next level with a force
experiment that became known as
laplace's demon since classical physics
explained
every reaction in existence laplace
reasoned
we could theoretically understand the
causes and effects
that had led us to any point in time we
could also predict the future
from that point in time onwards so
if there were some intelligence let's
call it
a demon or a god or a giant turnip named
patrick
capable of knowing all the forces
operating in the universe
and the exact location of every particle
in the universe
that intelligence would be able to
explain everything
that had happened in the past and
predict everything
that would happen in the future and of
course there's not a lot of space for
free will when
every action is predictable and already
set in motion
the viability of laplace's turnip has
since been undermined by the discovery
of thermodynamic irreversibility
amongst other things but the idea we're
ruled by cause and effect and by
extension the implication we might not
be as responsible for our own actions
as we think we are hasn't gone away and
in 1983 american physiologist benjamin
lebet
conducted an experiment that rocked the
scientific world
by providing compelling evidence that we
don't
have free will lebet was monitoring
brain activity in individuals
by carrying out a very simple action
tapping their fingers on a table
his aim was to study how signals in our
brain turn into physical actions in the
real world
but during the experiment he noticed
something strange
he was measuring brain activity before
his test subjects reported having
consciously decided to act
in other words their brains were
initiating finger movement
before the subject had consciously made
the decision to move
as far as lebet was concerned this was
neurological proof
we are not masters of our actions our
brains are making decisions
before we're aware of them and somehow
covering up the evidence we think we're
acting autonomously
but it's all a trick of the mind it was
a bad day
for free will the results of lebet's
work became well known
for many ending the free will debate
forever
but more recent research suggests the
experiment may have been flawed in the
first place
that the brain activity labet was
interpreting as the initiator of finger
movement in his subjects
might have been little more than
background brain activity
muddying his results in 2012
neuroscientist aaron sherga re-ran
lebet's experiments
with a few tweaks accounting for this
possibility
and found that our brains might not be
making sneaky decisions without
us knowing about them after all the game
was back on for free will
sherga's research has definitely not
proved free will is a real thing
but it has forced a rethink of
determinism
well of the hard variety at least hard
is the type we've been talking about up
until now the belief that free will
and the deterministic universe are
incompatible
it's one or the other but soft
determinism
usually referred to as compatibilism is
the view that
free will and determinism can co-exist
for compatibilists this allows us to
avoid simplifying the full complexity of
human experience down to a
series of physical laws a process known
as reductionism
it also opens up space for the
uncertainty kicked up by quantum physics
hard determinism has its roots in the
laws of classical physics
but these rules don't apply at a quantum
level a rather inconvenient issue that
happens to be one of the biggest
unsolved problems in physics
scientists have yet to find a theory of
everything to explain the way the whole
universe works
from the super big to the subatomic and
until then
they have to accept that the quantum
world and the macro world
mostly operate according to different
laws
with all this in mind the closest thing
we can find to casual determinism
at the quantum level are determined
probabilities
for example it may not be possible to
predict the trajectory of a subatomic
particle
in the same way you can accurately
predict the trajectory of a planet
or a frisbee but particles all obey
determined predictabilities
that give them a degree of
predictability some people
including einstein argue there are
hidden variables
we simply can't see that would account
for gaps in our ability to predict
quantum behavior
and if we knew these the universe would
be
fully deterministic we could predict
everything
but this is hotly debated by other
physicists
regardless of which side you take
quantum physics currently casts
reasonable doubt on the idea of
determinism
basically if the world around us is
inherently unpredictable
true determinism can't exist of course
the big question
is not do you have free will but rather
why should you care sure most of us like
to think we have free will
because we prefer to feel like we make
our own choices
but if we are actually just highly
sophisticated robots or puppets
acting out the inevitable drama of a
deterministic
universe what difference does that
really make
we still feel like we make our own
decisions so
everything ends up the same well
for one thing it could alter how
forgiving we are
of each other's behavior take for
example the case of charles whitman
a u.s marine known as the infamous texas
tower sniper
on the 1st of august 1966 whitman killed
his mother and wife
before heading to the university of
texas where
he proceeded to kill another 14 people
and wound 31 before police shot him dead
it remains one of the most horrific
shootings in american history
but a recent study questions whether
whitman was truly responsible for his
actions
doctors performing the autopsy on
whitman's body found a brain tumor
pressing against his amygdala
a part of the brain critical to
emotional regulation and behavioral
control
whitman was one of 17 cases involved in
a study that looked at examples of
criminal behavior
committed by people with brain lesions
even though the research subjects had
brain lesions in different parts of
their brains
the lesions were all found in places
connected to a neurological system
dubbed
the criminality-associated network
this network is closely linked with
brain structures related to moral
judgment and decision making
and researchers believe disruptions to
these brain systems
could have been responsible for the
individual's criminal behavior
this conclusion raises some difficult
questions about free will
and how responsible any of us are for
our own decisions
if our actions can be influenced so
significantly by events in our brains
how much choice do we really have in
what we do
where do we draw the line of moral and
legal responsibility
in the end is there really so much
difference between us
and honey stealing bears thanks for
watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you